[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
toy soldiers a shot here
[Applause]
that song
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you never forget the one who steals your
heart
or the one oh who kicks your ass Oh some
[ __ ] you [ __ ] is happening our Beach
and my balls say we need to go over
there and check it out
good Valley damage we're lifeguards my
bald a he's just thinking he's right for
my balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies they watch work because we
follow rules
this guy trainwrecks back never OD and
not a single [ __ ] was given it was a bet
formers in the whole world like if a
human [ __ ] jet which is impossible to
be so cool maybe there's you got don't
jack off on my sheet remember I'm always
watching Leon
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
back amount
all things considered being strung out
about work
but that's a good luck pick it up this
is for my dog we need to search for more
for evidence
check his paint for needle marks woman
check his paint lift his [ __ ] scrotum
and check his taint - taint man it ain't
even look get closer
oh holy Kyogre oh there's a hole that's
just his butthole smile most of that do
not post at this a handful of ball sack
[Music]
he turns two nails into the goddamn X
game because we were in lifeguard
pursuit oh okay love it
except for there's no [ __ ] such thing
as lifeguard pursuit
[Music]
you